why don't we go next to oh I don't know
it's just it's the the phone lines are
just packed folks packed let's go to
Eric from Philly Eric from Philly
welcome to the program what's going on
and you gotta unmute yourself There You
Go mute sorry about that
um thank you very much I knew you were
going to pick me as soon as I went
through the drive-thru
um okay quick question for you please do
you think Republicans are going with the
arming teachers
um argument because they think it's a go
nowhere issue because I really don't
believe Society is going to be okay with
army I actually I don't know I mean I
think that there are private schools
that there might even be some private
schools that have done it and maybe some
that will but I do think you're right
that as a matter of public schools
teachers aren't going to be armed
anytime soon and part of what
Republicans need is anytime somebody
like me proposes you know 10 different
things we could do about gun safety they
say no to all of them and some of those
Republicans and right-wingers and gun
people would like to at least be able to
pretend that they're offering something
as opposed to just saying no and so I
think part of what you're suspecting is
correct which is they go well let's arm
teachers and let's lock the doors or
whatever just so they can say we're not
saying saying do nothing here's what we
want to do and of course they're never
really going to have to legislate it
because Public Schools I I would never
say never Eric because never is a long
time but at any time soon we are not
going to see teachers armed at Public
Schools
all right thanks for answering my
question I appreciate it
all right Eric from Philly thank you
very much great to hear from you